what do you think I'm grabbing off
camera right now bad try guess guess
guess 3 2 1 guess it's a deal of popcorn
hi my name is first I'll leave did not
know now you know your life is different
now this is exciting it's Friday the
world stuff so why don't we just talk
about some of the good that's going on
it's time for another good news is this
is a segment on my YouTube channel where
I just tell you about some news that
I've seen or read that is either
delightful or dumb or both let's dive
right in Olympics
one sport I'm really good at is choking
alone in my own house while I'm eating
snacks to pass the first story I saw on
Twitter moments called badass grandpa
and it was someone that tweeted someone
longer my grandpa preferred see for
elderly people on the subway and he did
this he did this yeah what also what I
don't know if I'm more impressed with
that physicality or that facial
expression why am I feeling such sexual
urges one is this Brazilian George
Clooney 2 is this this man's audition
tape for the most interesting man in the
world 3 is this just an Old Spice
commercial and we're all being duped
either way [ __ ]
goodness is Bart on Bart I didn't read
this story in its entirety but it looks
like a bunch of people in San Francisco
took the BART which is the public
transportation system in that city
wearing Bart Simpson masks and here's
some of what went down yeah I love
everything about this it's just dumb and
fun and it doesn't hurt anyone I don't
know if there was any sort of like
socio-political thing associated with
this and I kind of hope that there isn't
one I hope that this is just a random
act of weird and that makes me love it
all the more well thanks you love it all
the most is this video of all the Bart's
getting off of the subway trying so hard
to keep those stupid masks on that
clearly affect their vision
that's very athletic
good job Bart on Bart good news is by
really I mean I have nothing else to say
but my life is different now here's some
good news some of the gymnasts at the
Rio Olympics this year wore socks during
the competition straight up socks
there's a lot of theories about it the
major one is that some gymnasts wear
socks to grip the floor when they're
tumbling it's used kind of like chalk it
absorbs the moisture so if you have
sweaty feet it's helpful I guess but the
most helpful part about it is how
hilariously looks look at that that that
looks like someone at BuzzFeed Photoshop
some socks off that gymnast something's
not good about it but it's ultimately
not bad either I'm all for this plus it
sets the bar for the next Olympic Games
gymnast you gotta come with something
unexpected hats maybe I think that could
be very cool helmets in addition to this
good news is Michael Buckley
is the most emphatic enthusiastic
audience member of the Olympics that
might have ever existed in real life his
raging love for gymnastics is incredible
to watch and he's made a few videos
recapping the Olympics so far so I
highly encourage you watch them because
they make me laugh so hard
there's nothing but joy and excitement
just oozing out of every pore of that
man's body and I just good news is
here's some headlines that made me laugh
lately artist
turn yourself into Buster Bluth for some
reason it's not even the content of that
article that makes
laughs it's that the writer just clearly
gave know about this like chess Co given
to crafting a headline god they're like
let me cover Zika and we cover Zika let
me cover Zika oh I got a cover makeup
artist turning herself into buster bluth
great here here's my makeup artist turn
yourself into Buster blue for some
reason done I'm done
Beyonce goes jet skiing and a floor like
jumpsuit it goes why the [ __ ] not you
know who probably told those gymnasts to
wear socks Beyonce why because she wears
a floor-length jumpsuit when she jet
skis but it is Mashable reported a story
about the photo of a seagull standing on
top of another seagull and I'm happy
that this made news I don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on with these evils
but doesn't seem wrong or bad also there
are some conspiracy theories that this
might be photoshopped and if this is
Photoshop that makes it better for some
reason why would you be at home
photoshopping a seamless idiot oh
another single this also happened in
Australia does that make it more
understandable nature is beautiful
you know it gives us sunsets it gives us
the miracle of birth and it gives us
seagulls just standing on top of other
seagulls I don't know if this is
bullying or if this is like friendship
or this is courtship or this is I ship
it it's something extremely delightful
about this the seagull on the bottom
doesn't seem to really care single the
top seems like it really wants that
single on the bottom to care god I just
want to walk across the street like the
head oh I have talked for hours about
what does this mean we're gonna put a
trench coat around you and then pretend
that you're a regular sized human
walking around Australian good news is
if you live in the United States if
you're over the age of 18 are allowed
the wonderful privilege of voting and it
is so incredibly important in this
election especially and voting in be
overwhelming or weird because you might
not know how to do it but the good news
is
Green has you covered he created an
entire YouTube channel that explains how
you can vote in every state in the
United States so I'm gonna link it right
here but they fit anything go check it
out super simple really straightforward
and incredibly helpful so please I
encourage you to check it out good news
is this story is absolutely beautiful I
saw on Huffington Post strangers like
Pokemon go with teen with autism after
he was called the art word happen
Arizona a boy and his mom were playing
Pokemon go and these two like college
students came over and called them the R
word and like squirted barbecue sauce on
him which is just so ugly so ugly a
boy's sister posted about it on Facebook
and it went pretty viral and then dozens
of strangers brought the boy gifts and
played Pokemon go with him and oh god it
just ah it's a beautiful story and also
just a friendly daily reminder that if
you see anyone being bullied you can
change that you can step in and stand up
for what is good and right and wonderful
and kind about being a human being
so good that's it for this episode of
good news is let me know any of the good
news that you guys have seen or anything
that made you laugh this week and don't
forget if you like this video or if you
hated this video please subscribe to my
youtube channel because we are just
creepin and crawlin up to that three mil
mark and I got some ideas on what to do
they do not involve fart masks but they
could involve that grandpa uh uh he's
busy he's too cool I don't know yeah we
wear the socks for grip because they're
sweaty feet no you wear the socks cuz
balance' I told you - it all makes sense
now